2017's It has been scaring audiences everywhere
since its release, but for all the terror
Pennywise is causing on the big screen, the
novel contains even more horrifying scenes
that had to be cut from the film.
Here are the scariest moments from It that
were too terrifying to leave the book.
Ben's first encounter
Early in the novel, Ben Hanscom is shown volunteering
to stay late to help his teacher finish some
last-minute tasks, and by the time they're
done, the streets have cleared.
Even though it's brutally cold, Ben decides
to walk home alone.
Along the way, he spots a clown standing on
the ice, clutching balloons and offering Ben
one, with his usual offer for the kid to float.
What's frightening about it is that Ben does
want that balloon and feels sucked into Pennywise's
mental grip, which is only broken by the town's
clock chiming to indicate the top of the hour.
Talk about being saved by the bell.
The werewolf
The It movie did a great job of sneaking in
a lot of the pop culture-inspired monsters
that loomed large over the Losers, but the
werewolf at the Neibolt Street house only
appeared in a blink-and-you'd-miss-it moment.
As in the movie, the werewolf arrives during
Bill and Richie's journey into the house.
But while Richie's perspective shows It as
the four-legged freak show, Bill sees something
different.
As they escape on Bill's bike Silver, he describes
It as a clown in a varsity coat, which runs
counter to Richie's memory of the monster.
It's a subtle difference, but the scene proves
that It looks different to different people
depending on their particular fear, which
makes it that much scarier than some bozo
with big teeth.
The absence of the wolf also means that the
book's weapon — silver slugs — aren't
a factor in the movie, which is why the Losers
end up fighting with a bolt gun instead of
their trusty slingshot.
The standpipe
Although Stan's first encounter with It in
the movie takes place in his father's office,
the literary version is a lot creepier.
As a child, Stan is an avid bird watcher and
heads down to the Barrens to do some spotting
near the Standpipe — a notoriously off-limits
part of town, since it claimed too many lives
when it was open to the public.
After seeing the Standpipe appear to float,
Stanley goes inside.
The door shuts, locking him in, and he hears
a voice claiming to be "the dead ones."
He only manages to escape by chanting the
names of birds from his guidebook.
Despite what he's seen, Stan still has trouble
wrapping his head around what's happened and
needs more proof of It's existence.
This all goes to show, of course, that Stan
has more trouble accepting It than the rest,
which will have deadly consequences for him
later in life.
Georgie's picture
In the It movie, the kids' projector slideshow
develops a mind of Its own and slowly churns
out a more-than-photorealistic image of Pennywise.
That might be a clever way of getting the
feel of the scene across while embracing the
movie's adjusted timeline, but there's still
something particularly sinister about the
way this moment goes down in the book.
As reimagined by the TV miniseries as well,
Bill looks at a photo album with some innocent
family pictures of Georgie.
But one photo of his lost little brother starts
to move, winking at him and promising that
he'll see him soon — just before the book
starts gushing blood.
Making matters worse is that the image represents
Bill's freshest memory of Georgie, since it
was taken just days before his death.
Sure, the It movie brought Georgie back to
terrorize Bill, but the scene as written is
a spine-tingler all on its own.
The disappearance of Chad Lowe
Other than Betty Ripsom and Patrick Hockstetter,
the children who've gone missing in the 2017
movie are largely ignored, which means the
movie also passes over one of the most disturbing
disappearances of all: Chad Lowe.
Grown-up Mike Hanlon makes mention of the
boy later when recapping the town's attitude
towards the missing kids, pointing out Chad's
case to the cop who wants to wave away the
deaths or disappearances as coincidence.
Lowe was just three and a half when he went
missing the same year the Losers made their
first stand against It.
Granted, Pennywise has never seemed to care
about the ages of his victims; after all,
Georgie's just six when he's snatched away
on the street.
But little Chad is still just a toddler, which
makes his probable death even more gruesome.
It's a footnote to the whole story of It,
but an especially unsettling one.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!